well I think the Americans are certainly
very ambitious better to do a deal as
fast as possible what we're saying to
them is yes we want to go fast and we
share their optimism and their
enthusiasm but we want it to be a big
and comprehensive free trade deal so
it's got to go beyond just trade in in
goods in in agriculture and all that
kind of thing because you know that
those are quite limited we don't want to
see what you can do insert the C's we
want to see what you can do is I was
saying to the president earlier on in
shipping Cabot college and aviation
Cabot are you to tell you one thing if
you're if you're a British architect or
or an insurance company you have
unbelievable barriers to establishing in
the the US in the way that an American
architectural American lawyer or
whatever does not face barriers in the
UK so there's a huge amount of progress
that needs to be made but listen the
president is full of beans he's very
enthusiastic and and so much so I think
there's a transition working group we've
established a working group and we're
going to get on with it very fast I just
see you I just don't want I know you're
inviting me to sell it set a deadline do
that but but I have long experience of
the Americans as trade negotiators they
are formidable we will get a great deal
you'll get a great deal but it may it
may take some time
mr. Don small fuse back home want to
know those where we are on breakfast yes
the eight days to go they're not sure
where we're heading is no deal still a
million to one chance
look no deal a deal depends entirely on
our friends here some of them here our
partners across the EU and I think in
the last few days we've actually had
quite a lot of success in landing some
messages about what the UK that can do
and can do what I say
so you know if I'm let's be let's be
clear I think at the moment there's a
reasonable chance that we'll get a deal
but in order to get that deal to repeat
my message we've got to prepare to come
out with a snow chance it's not million
to one though is it becoming more likely
or less likely after your mark on macro
meetings I think that you know I'm a
doctor I think the chances of a deal
are improving but there's got to be a
great deal of realism on the part of our
friends that the withdrawal agreement is
dead with the text that parliament
rejected three times cannot now be made
to go through and I know people are
people think what is all about
fundamentally the problem with that
withdrawal agreement is it would keep
the UK locked in the EU viewers at home
don't necessarily understand this it
would keep us locked in the --use
trading arrangements and in the the
mooner pull of EU law without being able
to have a say on that that's why it's
totally all exist and that but did you
tower president macron and Angela Merkel
that you are planning to withhold a
nearly 30 billion or 30 billion of the
withdraw divorce bill of 39 billion
pounds did you tell them that you were
going to withhold that money when you
met them this week was that my things I
think what the the entire community what
the entire European Union understands is
that if we come out without a deal then
the 39 billion men did you is not make
that well that's been made clear did you
think they understand that if it's
forgive me if there isn't a deal then
the thirty nine billion is no longer
legally pledged and as I've said many
many times we were therefore on the
first of November have very substantial
sums available from that 39 billion to
spend on supporting our investment in
all sorts of women of areas that chance
of a No Deal to now it being more likely
and for viewers at home what they
actually want to know is can you promise
them that there will not be medicine
shortages that there will not be food
shortages in the days after October make
that license what I can tell people and
as I said a few weeks ago on the steps
of Daniel Street I think that we can get
through this I think this is a great
great country the UK and we can we can
easily cope with a No Deal scenario I
know that that's what people want I
frankly I think it's pretty unlike that
that paper was was based on assumptions
that were made before we'd really
started accelerating our preparations
what I also said to people is that there
may be bumps on the road but that we
will get through them and it's
absolutely vital that we make the
preparations now all the assessments
you're not being straight with people
we've been very very frank with people
about what is what they need and there's
a massive program of engagement with
businesses large and small with the
farming community well we are making
every possible preparation and I think
that that is what the public would want
us to do I also think that what the
public wants is to get ready for a No
Deal brexit for two reasons the first is
that that is the best way to ensure that
we get the deal but that I think we can
get but the other reason obviously is so
that if and when we are forced by the
obduracy of our European friends to come
out on October 31st
without a deal that things are as smooth
as they can possibly be
so I'm full of of course
that's about it I do think that you know
there's going to be a lot of work still
to be done before October 31st but a
huge amount is being done as you know
that we are reaching out to consumer
groups to businesses across the country
the whole time
and when we come out we will then have
substantial opportunities that we
haven't had before opportunities to do
things differently in our con
opportunities to cut taxes on it cut
taxes on investment opportunities to
regulate in a different way
opportunities to do free trade deals and
that is something I think we can all
look forward to the people who are going
to be responsible for No Deal are not in
the in the UK we don't want it's up to
you as but it's simply not possible for
us to have an agreement that contains
the the backstop in the way that I've
described keeps us locked in the EU
arrangements in the way that I was right
at that point I think has now landed
with our friends and what we're hoping
is that they'll they'll see way forward